i work
as a social media executive and the
reason why i'm here is
just to prove to myself mentally that i
can still get into good shape but the
past sort of year's been quite difficult
probably i'm going to comment most
probably about how big he is because
i always fascinated by massive guys just
because i'm so small
that sounded really wrong that sounded
terribly wrong i didn't mean it in that
way
for that i'm gonna give you two huh yes
oh there it is
you said you had you've been in shape
before you've had a six-pack i went
through a bit of a transformation
before was it 2012 so seven years ago
you had a set of apps
basically that's what we want to kind of
get back to you ready to get it on ready
man
right i'm gonna bring the team in all
right luke and chris
are you ready yes let's get the body
fat's done with luke wicked
watch hank on a good day five six but
we'll go five five
everyone in here allows me to have a
good job that's a recurring thing
anxiety i've always suffered with i work
just only what two three months ago
i'm not going to the toilet just to you
know basically have a panic attack
i've been there myself not alone yeah
even the world's strongest man has uh
yeah and his bad days and he's locked
himself on the toilet at school
and at work and also so nothing
reassuring
easy down we go
[Applause]
yes come on yeah good
okay one good good
come on
well done mate that was incredible
man honestly mate that's awesome
[Applause]
[Music]
14 don't stop 15 come on
[Applause]
right mate no rest
[Music]
all right let's get it fast feet cross
feet it's a quick match good this is
good place mate keep it up keep it up
squeeze those hands squeeze them
come on mate come on
get it harder come on
get your arms up higher come on reach
them down
that's not bad okay there's one more
thing we need for you before we let you
go and that's the before this time
one more thing no this is a picture now
so no more exercises
from the front to 90 degrees that way
biceps big growl i can't even regroup
thank you i want these abs to reappear
interesting really
nice thank you just
what do you cheers guys yeah mass
really good it's also nice to hear
somebody else
speak openly about anxiety and
depression because that's really
important to
to get rid of that stigma and to break
down the walls of that brick bar brick
yeah really impressive mazel around i
think he'll absolutely smash it talking
to smashing it there's a cheesecake
upstairs with my name on it
good day guys
because we've got six weeks to
absolutely smash it so only an hour in
i'm sure i can do another six weeks easy
[Music]
right so i've just finished meal
prepping for the first week we've got
some chicken
nuts and then we've got some runny beans
and some mixed veg what's your ankle as
they say
[Music]
i've missed training today currently i'm
playing on a date
blowing no alcohol for the virgin
monitor
right it's currently saturday night um
i've done a day of
gym i've gone for a run you know i fancy
a bit of a treat and i've made like sort
of like a fake chinese chicken saturday
hey mars hope you're well buddy i'm
sending chris and luke to check up on
you
and give you some support but well done
mate just keep at it
big love the beast hello
welcome to my humble abode i've
literally been here for less than
three months now just getting settled in
and stuff like that how are you getting
on
yeah it's been tough because we were a
little bit worried to be fair you've
been quite quiet
yeah yeah i think i'm one of those
people i just like to uh
sort of just get on with it so once i've
been sort of set a goal i'll just sort
of just smash with it food wise
yeah i'm starving so come on oh yeah
let's go yeah
oh yeah that's left over chicken
leftover from
the meal prep uh we also got chicken
garlic onion for when
this is just like for example today i'll
probably use that today and then all the
meal prep boxes are for when i'm at work
he's not looking convinced i don't know
what's wrong is that good i don't
remember sweet corn being on it
yeah is that bad no it's a cabinet so
these ones i was meant to look at
because they haven't got anything
yeah yeah they're like the ones yeah
this does make you like a psycho though
doesn't it
doesn't look great for me right now but
i just think it's organization do i mean
it's organization
yeah that was before we started and
that's needs to go in the bin somewhere
and that that one needs to go as well uh
that was all before can we just
disclaimer that was all before i started
so
what's that for uh that i don't know how
that got in there
that must have just stuck in somehow so
like when we're saying that you're 100
on the diet if i'm not quite oh i'm sort
of following it yeah how many other bits
you saw
of course it's like taking shortcuts
isn't it yeah that's fine no i need i
need that
just to give me all this right now i'm
getting exposed there
yes yes what's going on it's going away
good yes
hey man mate we're in i think he's
actually killed me with that
i actually found a lot of stuff in my
fridge is he always been like this in
terms of discipline he let's lose
sometimes though
let's lose a lot to be fair like he's
all right like he had one period where
he was like in really good shape
uh i've not drank since january so
nothing at all no literally nothing's
obvious
right obviously with my anxiety and
stuff it's just not good
one time went away we had a really big
heavy weekend
and um basically i had a major panic
attack at the airport
and ended up in hospital it was bad it
was one of the problem
what was the worst panic attack i've
ever had i literally was about to die
yeah and i thought some heart attacks
my muscles started seizing up and stuff
no one really believed in they didn't
have the anxiety until basically we went
away into budapest
that was that was the trigger and then
after it was
it went downhill pretty quick after that
i was just like yeah this isn't for me
you know that's what it is it's live
yeah yeah that's pretty good
i've got no excuses whatsoever from now
on i'm going to stick to it
marty's looking he's got me to answer to
today and not head because mazda's got a
bit of an excuse for everything
he's found his own little way to mangle
everything every aspect of that in
every aspect of the training so i'm not
really sure whether maz is actually
going to make it work
so it's 11 a.m it's the second night
i haven't been able to sleep properly i
think maybe sort of the realization of
what's going on has hit me getting out
of bed like motivation is
just not not there
hey maz how are you doing buddy i'm good
thanks mate you yeah good you look
fitter now if you mate how how's
everything going mate how was the the
transformation have you have you lost
weight
he's going all right last couple of days
been a bit of a struggle uh just with
like for example sleep
so the past three nights not been
sleeping at all um so getting up and
trying to train is very difficult and
very little sleep
well i i saw that you posted a picture
of a curry on your instagram the other
day
what's all that about
i mean bottom line buddy was it on the
list of foods for you to eat
or not no so you so you're like me
oh i don't like to use that word
so just want to say mate it's all on you
you know if this diet doesn't
pull off if the regime doesn't quite go
to plan
in a few weeks time you come back and
you're not seeing the results it's all
on you man
my eyes are new buddy i'm going to keep
an eye on you so no more cheating all
right might as well take time mate and
good luck with everything
cheers mate all right bud take care man
i really like maz you know he's a really
nice guy
he's he's obviously put a lot of effort
in the past he's a very
sort of say what you need to hear kind
of guy um
i hope and prove wrong i hope he can
stick to the diet stick to the training
and come and
and shut my mouth and i've always
suffered with anxiety
my whole life but the crazy thing i woke
up one day i was like this is mad
why do i feel like this and i couldn't
sort of pinpoint everything sort of
hit at once and i was having very dark
thoughts or you know
things that i don't like um yes
sorry
what what what is going to make you
happy or proud or like what you're
expecting
just to know that i've done it um just
to be able to say that you know i've
stuck to a program i've been disciplined
but mentally just to be able to sort of
know that i've done something else
something that's the sort of thing
so when's the last time you saw him in
person two three weeks ago
for a family dinner before they started
we went to tenerife
for a stag dude right yeah and he didn't
look good was that
was that before or after we i got it
that was before
just before oh it was horrendous okay
so have you guys been supportive of mars
have you been sending me messages or
have you been dragging into corey houses
he doesn't even need it he um i think it
was like an awakening
when he when we saw him last that he
actually has to take this very seriously
and there's a lot of people that's
behind him as well i mean i can't wait
to see him really want to head down and
get him in yeah okay come on
let's do it
[Music]
really good 71 kilos last time
and he's down to 67.4 his lean mass was
54.2
it's now 54.8 and he's dropped 4.9
percent body fat
wow deadlift was 110 kilos that's what
we're gonna have a look at now i think
deadlifts
right so this is ten kilowatt what we
did last time yeah okay
yes good luck i think 140. tight
keep pointing forward come on man
yeah easy
i think there's more in there
lad you want to keep going okay
come on mate same again come on come on
if we can put another five on you'll be
pulling two and a half times body weight
ready
well that's awesome buddy i mean
percentage-wise that's that's a big
increase
i suppose the last thing is to get your
top off and let's
visually see the difference
are you ready to see yourself yeah six
weeks ago compared to now yeah anybody
can see the difference that's mine
you've got to see me it's it's hella
impressive yeah amazing
they don't normally this nice i don't
have to react
that is really good i'm proud of how far
i've come it's equipped me with all the
right tools
um you know using gym as a way of
fighting anxiety for example you know
mentally just having a half an hour just
exercising is going to do so much for
you
you know in hindsight i could have put
maybe five percent 10 extra in but no
i'm proud of what i've achieved how far
i've come
give me the kick up the bum that i
needed to carry on really
so much more i can say really i mean
it's been absolutely fantastic visually
we've done our job you know you came to
get beasted
you've definitely been beasted awesome
cheerful man appreciate it i'll get you
good
you